let's begin by exploring the different
storage options available in Google
Cloud
every application needs to store data
like media to be streamed or perhaps
even sensor data from devices
and different applications and workloads
require different storage database
Solutions
Google Cloud offers relational and
non-relational databases and worldwide
object storage
these options help users save costs
reduce the time it takes to launch and
make the most of their data sets by
being able to analyze a wide variety of
data
choosing the right option to store and
process data often depends on the data
type that needs to be stored and the
business need
Google Cloud provides managed storage
and database services that are scalable
reliable and easy to operate
these include cloud storage Cloud SQL
Cloud spanner firestore and bigtable
the goal of these products is to reduce
the time and effort needed to store data
this means creating an elastic storage
bucket directly in a web interface or
through a command line
there are three common cloud storage use
cases
the first is content storage and
delivery this is when content such as
images or videos need to be served to
users wherever they are
people want their content fast so
running on the global Network that
Google provides makes for a great
experience for end users
the Second Use case is storage for data
analytics and general compute
users can process or expose their data
to analytics tools like the analytics
stack of products that Google Cloud
offers and do things like genomic
sequencing or iot data analysis
the third use case is backup and
archival storage
users can save storage costs by
migrating infrequently accessed content
to cheaper cloud storage options
also if anything happens to their data
on premises it's critical to have a copy
in the cloud for Recovery purposes
for users with databases Google's first
priority is to help them migrate
existing databases to the cloud and move
them to the right service
this will usually be users moving MySQL
or post great workloads to Cloud SQL
the second priority is to help users
innovate build or rebuild for the cloud
offer mobile applications and plan for
future growth